so I'm gonna need to keep this thing
moving are you gonna bang the average
gavel hammers calls gavel hey legal
eagles let's think like a lawyer today
we are covering the highly requested
episode of It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia mcpoyle vs. Ponderosa the
trial of the century this is
particularly exciting for me because I
think by the end of this episode we will
finally solve the mystery of why people
keep asking me if I know anything about
bird law I have no idea what that means
but I think it originates in this
episode of It's Always Sunny so let's
dig in and find out remember to comment
in the form of an objection which I will
either sustain or overrule and while
you're there let me know what movie or
TV show I should do next and of course
stick around until the end when I give
this episode of It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia a grade for legal realism
so without further ado let's dig in to
mcpoyle vs. Ponderosa the trial of the
century yeah Billy you gotta relax okay
Uncle Jack and I we've got this case
alright now now listen to me liam
mcpoyle is gonna come at you hard
alright but but I've done my research I
got something with this bird there all
right there's the birds keep your eye on
a prize this goes well it's party time
what is that dude I need you keeping him
please alright that's why you're here I
gotta have the drugs here to keep them
clean make sense dad does not make sense
okay
so within the first 30 seconds of this
episode someone has brought a bag full
of drugs into court somehow I'm going to
go out on a limb and say that this is
not going to be the most accurate legal
drama I have ever reviewed don't bring
drugs into court bad idea very likely to
get searched very likely to be arrested
don't bring drugs to court oh man
everybody's got a thing don't leave me
out and Frank's got a thing Dee's gotta
think dennis has got a thing dennis has
the thing you're talking about oh dude
what are you doing here there's got to
be a way to get this court to let me out
of my alimony payments me if you guys
see Maureen and the woman has gone
almost full cat
so not only would that distract from his
case but there is absolutely no way that
an unrelated party can go in and request
a family law matter be thrown on the
docket of a Superior Court family law
courts and the superior courts are two
completely separate entities the family
law courts handle things like divorces
and child support they do not handle
your general jurisdiction civil lawsuits
that's what the Superior Court is for
the Superior Court is where you'll end
up if you have a civil lawsuit they have
different judges and they have
completely different sets of laws that
they are going to apply on a daily basis
and you can't just show up in court one
day and ask that something be thrown on
the docket because your ex-wife is
pretending to be a cat you'll be dealing
with me today and you'll be dealing with
me today Jack Kelly lawyer good to see
you again are those fake hands know what
hey you know what good luck with all of
that today so in reality before you even
get close to a courtroom you're gonna go
through a process called discovery
discovery is the process by which you
get information from the other side and
the other side gets information from you
you are allowed to request relevant
documents you're allowed to ask the
other side questions and you are allowed
to question them in person under oath
through depositions so before you ever
get close to a courtroom you're going to
have to interact with the other side
whether you want to or not
many many times through discovery there
is no longer any trial by sandbagging
you have to turn over relevant
information to the other side and the
other side has to turn over relevant
information to you so you would never
just introduce yourself for the first
time at trial this episode appears to
have skipped through one of the largest
portions of a civil lawsuit okay we have
mcpoyle versus Ponderosa seeking damages
for the loss of an eye in the form of a
one-time payment to the sum of $200 are
the plaintiffs present okay the judge
would never ever let it proceed to trial
that is such a small amount number one
it should be in small claims court not
the general jurisdiction of the Superior
Court
which can take any amount in controversy
up to millions or billions of dollars
it's funny that the judge here has made
a snide remark because it's not
realistic for a 200-dollar matter to go
forward it's crazy
Your Honor if I may Charlie Kelly
co-counsel a background in bird law no
but excited to be in the People's Court
and a big fan of black judges to stop
cutting me oh boy okay so I don't think
Charlie Kelly here has a law jury I
don't think he has passed the bar he
cannot introduce himself as a lawyer
here and I think that that is a problem
for his co-counsel who actually is a
lawyer I think because of the
representation as a lawyer that's a
potential grounds for sanctions by the
bar here both for Charlie but also the
co-counsel this is not normal at all
okay
look all I need are the facts to this
case I have a very long day ahead of me
so I'm gonna need to keep this thing
moving are you gonna bang the gavel
hammers called gavel my client is odd
you might even refer to his family is
very creepy but they are Saints compared
to Bill Ponderosa and the sordid lot of
degenerates he associates with terrible
people who ruin lives ruined mine cost
my client is marriage ruin my my second
one is teetering you're not allowed to
bring in character evidence except under
very specific circumstances none of
which are present here character
evidence is where you're saying that
someone has a certain character for
acting in a certain way and therefore
they likely acted in that way that is in
conformity with their character on a
specific instance court's I think
rightfully look down on that kind of
tenuous specious argument and they don't
allow that to come in except under very
rare circumstances and additionally in
an opening statement you are not
supposed to be arguing which is what
this attorney is doing so despite
claiming to be a very good lawyer he's
not doing a great job so far it looks
like he's allowing his personal bias to
enter into his opening statement your
honor I'll keep it brief I just have
three things to say one liam mcpoyle has
a history of lying - that's character
this is a loving family man and three
more character evidence he is innocent
oh boy okay so that lawyers opening
statement was actually very similar to
the other lawyers opening statement it
is filled with character evidence
sometimes you can bring in someone's
character for truthfulness that is
slightly different than normal character
evidence but still that opening
statement is number one terrible number
two strange because he's wearing these
giant hands for some reason and number
three this lawyer didn't explain or
provide any facts as to why his client
is innocent of the things that are being
alleged against him and I'm not even
sure what's going on here other than
claiming that there was a loss of the
use of one eye but neither of the
lawyers here have done a very good job
in their opening statements at all are
they going to explain why he's wearing
giant hands I'm gonna stop you right now
are you just gonna talk about your hands
for a while uh no your honor no more
questions for the witness
DeAndre here is the statement that you
gave to police okay the order of this
questioning is totally backwards the
plaintiff bears the burden and so they
have to call their witnesses first and
then when you call a witness you
question that witness first you then get
a cross-examination and then under some
circumstances you get a redirect
examination of the witness it is not at
all clear that the plaintiff has done
the first round of questioning I think
for dramatic effect they switch through
the order of the questioning bill did it
that drug addict is out of his mind I'll
testify to that and I swear on my
mother's grave that bill spiked that
milk no doubt about it he's guilty
guilty guilty so here he doesn't
actually get an answer from the witness
so there wasn't actually any testimony
that was elicited not that there was a
jury listening but the judge may
actually care what's on the record and
what is not on the record and all he's
done here has asked a question and
elicited no response from the witness
and therefore he hasn't gotten any
evidence that will help him in this
trial now this document may also be
hearsay it sounds like it might have
been a sworn statement to police so
under some circumstances that might not
be hearsay remember that hearsay is an
out-of-court statement used to prove the
truth of the matter asserted here he is
definitely using it for the truth the
matter asserted that Bill Ponderosa is
guilty or liable for whatever he's being
accused of but the main problem here is
that he hasn't gotten an answer from the
witness and he hasn't entered this
document into evidence so there's no
evidence to talk about right now I'm
sorry what did you say he spiked it and
then he tried to bribe me no further
questions your honor
ma'am do you know what perjury is mm-hmm
if you would like to know more about
what constitutes perjury or defamation
check out my episodes of real law review
which I'll link down below
I think dee would have benefited from
seeing some of those you know I feel
like I'm not being utilized properly
well that's is you don't have anything
so you're not being utilized at all yeah
but what if I get to deliver the
bombshell oh this is what bombs show you
guys will have a bombshell oh my god
every good case needs a bombshell
oh Jesus Christ without it you're
screwed oh you know what you know what
I'll find one for you I'm gonna do like
a hero cop Mark Fuhrman thing sort of
transition into a Kato Kaelin yeah
in reality cases rarely have bombshells
that's the whole point of discovery is
not to be able to sandbag the other side
or to pull out some crazy theory or fact
in the middle of trial in reality you
want the case to end as soon as possible
whether that's through settlement or
through trial or through dismissal so
you don't want things to wait until the
end and in real life you don't have
bombshells those are disposed of a long
long time before you ever get to court
your honor nothing represents the tragic
aftermath
more than the dramatic transformation of
this woman and cat excuse me as I
transition from woman to cat I must
insist on being referred to as a cat
objection
she's not a cat your honor so what is
the relevance of this testimony consider
herself a cat I will allow it I just
didn't know where all this is headed
how is this relevant well it's thank you
clearly relevant the attack had a
psychological impact on all the parties
that evening no further questions
okay first of all that has no relevance
as to whether the person did the thing
that they were accused of which is I
guess is spiking some milk with bath
salts and number two they're not suing
for psychological damages so all of this
testimony whatever psychological effect
it had on other people has no bearing on
this case and whether it injured other
people who are not plaintiffs here again
not relevant to this particular case so
all of this is irrelevant your honor
do you see what's going on here it's
just crazy see you don't I'm gonna I'm
gonna approach the bench no can I just
approach it real fast absolutely not
all right earlier you you referred to my
ex-wife as a cat for her request now
surely you wouldn't force a man to pay
alimony to a cat right so motion to
establish me not having to pay alimony
anymore I will not allow that okay well
so can we just google pop it on the
docket we can put at the end of the day
if you want us want to clear it up while
I got her in a courtroom I will not
allow that either sit down all right I
mean that was probably the right result
here there's no reason why he should
have this matter heard in front of this
judge in this court none of that is
related to family law I probably don't
need to tell you that people in the
gallery are not allowed to make legal
arguments or request relief from the
court he totally did it well then I
guess we will never know ladies and
gentlemen just confessed you did yes
yeah Ryan Steph Liam I totally saw it oh
my god we won
so you see this a lot in legal movies
and TV shows there will be one good
piece of evidence that comes out on the
stand and then suddenly everyone is
celebrating as if they have won the
court case this is not the end of the
game this is just the very beginning
there will be lots of other testimony
and rarely is one fact dispositive and
certainly not this particular fact Lyon
was Ryan drinking milk at the wedding of
course everyone was so who did the
stabbing doesn't matter your honor
because they were all still drugged on
Bill Ponderosa spiked milk which is the
point I've been trying to make the
entire time so just to be clear you've
proven my case you lose okay a couple of
things number one you're not allowed to
make argument in the middle of a
cross-examination this happens in movies
and TV shows but it is not realistic at
all you were allowed to ask questions
you are allowed to receive the answer
from the witnesses but you are not
allowed to just turn around and start
talking the judge and talking to the
other side and arguing your case ok mr.
McDonald you recently found out some
very interesting information care to
share it with the court yes I've
recently been informed that ryan mcpoyle
only drinks mother's milk which means
there's no way he could have drank the
milk
that bill spiked which means he was
sober when he attacked his brother which
means bill is innocent
case closed boom boom sure alright just
as an attorney is not allowed to make
argument during a cross-examination
neither can the witness go off and make
argument if he has evidence great state
your testimonies state your the
percipient facts that you personally
have witnessed but you can't then just
go on this tirade making argument about
what you can infer from the different
kinds of evidence so everybody's making
argument here it's very entertaining it
is not realistic at all how did you come
upon this information oh I banged
Margaret McCoy I'm curious how she told
you because Margaret is a mute
so here say either way I had to write it
down
all right just because she has written
this down does not make it any less here
say it is still an out-of-court
statement used for the truth of the
matter asserted
that only mother's milk is consumed by
the individual oh boy that's this is so
weird your honor
mother is the name of the mcpoyle family
cow the cow that provided the milk for
the wedding the milk that was drugged by
Bill Ponderosa second you lied to me for
sex
bombshell diffused a promise all right
so there are a lot of problems here the
lawyer is again making argument without
getting testimony from the witness you
need to save your argument for the
closing argument he's getting testimony
from someone sitting in the gallery just
call her to the stand you can have a
deaf or mute person testify through an
interpreter that's a very easy thing to
do and you have to enter this picture
that is being discussed into evidence
otherwise none of this counts at all
this is the mcpoyle family crest on it
you will find a bird a Pocono swallow to
be more accurate a very rare very
elusive bird you'll notice its trademark
unibrow highly uncommon in most aviary
circles and my research shows that
unlike your typical North American Barn
Swallow the the Poconos small if kept
under the proper conditions does this
have to do with anything even 85 years
much like a parrot or some of the more
resilient coastal gulls your honor
where's this going I don't know but a
bit of lead somewhere fancies gonna say
oh I can assure you that this will be
our final argument well if it's gonna
help end all of this madness Oh again
you're not allowed to just bring in
random posters into evidence you're not
allowed to make argument where there
should be some testimony going on
Charlie has said that this will
constitute their final argument but the
problem is a hundred percent of what he
is talking about never came out in court
so all of this is not an evidence you're
not allowed to make argument based on
facts that did not come out in the trial
at
self so all of this is improper whether
this is in place of testimony or whether
it's in place of argument it's all
ridiculous
it doesn't seem relevant at all and it's
100% improper pretty boys and girls
because here's where it gets good ryan
mcpoyle didn't attack liam royal did and
lion was lying about riot attacking liam
to protect royal from the chair or
lethal injection or perhaps some sort of
small bird guillotine I wouldn't
understand the physics of it I'm not an
executioner I'm just the best goddamn /
lawyer in the world ok I guess that
could be true he could be the best bird
lawyer in the world that's not really a
thing but he is one of the worst trial
lawyers I have ever seen he does nothing
but improperly argue at times when he
should be eliciting evidence he is
relying on speculation on facts not on
the record on hearsay on irrelevant
testimony he tried to get evidence out
of the gallery he tried to bring in new
evidence that hasn't come out during his
closing arguments he is basically
breaking every rule that exists in Civil
Procedure at this time this is the
biggest train wreck of a trial I've ever
seen in my entire life and I've seen a
lot of trials this is bad
so bottom line and listen up dumb nuts
because it blows a hole in your case
birds don't drink milk facts on an
evidence
improper opinion didn't the bailiff ask
everyone to remove their hats and it is
true mr. mcpoyle would you please remove
your head mmm mr. McCoy oh please remove
your hat perhaps he is too insane to
understand the question
why don't I just
so as ridiculous as this part is there
is actually a part of the Code of Civil
Procedure that does allow for a physical
inspection of the other side you have to
make a motion with the court and there
are certain hurdles that you have to go
through because you can imagine that
people could abuse the right to
physically inspect the other side or to
ask the other side to get a medical
examination but there are actual
provisions of the code that allow you to
do that when it is relevant to the
specific case who do Your Honor this is
mr. Belka my heir he's a professor of
Ornithology at the University of Penn
mr. my heir it's safe to say you're a
bit of an expert on birds yes I believe
you're correct and you would understand
this Pocono swallow quite well what are
you yes I do then please ask if an
attack glia okay I probably don't need
to tell you this but you are not allowed
to conduct a second examination of a
different witness while you have a first
witness on the stand in the first place
you just have to excuse the first one
then called the other person back up to
the stand if you need to redress issues
with the first witness you can call them
again as a rebuttal witness or ask for a
redirect but you're not allowed to have
someone sit at counsel table and ask
them separate questions he's not even
under oath this is all very very
improper my 35 years on this bench I
have never seen such a mockery made of
this courtroom you people have wasted my
time you've wasted the taxpayers time
and this justice has heard enough
finally this case out I should have done
it hours ago yes you should have thrown
out this case it was ridiculous this
Court has ruled now I suggest that you
people get the hell out of my courtroom
before I put you all in jail yeah rule
number one never piss off the judge
[Music]
okay now it's time to give mcpoyle
versus Ponderosa a grade for legal
realism so they didn't get a whole lot
right they had council tables and wood
panels on the walls on the other hand
you had lawyers making argument instead
of asking questions you have neither
side really getting any evidence out you
have facts that were never mentioned at
any point so they basically get
everything wrong now I've never done
this but I think this episode of It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia deserves a
flat F I would not allow this in my
court do you agree
leave your objections down below and
check out my other reactions over here
we're as always I will see you in court